Jake: 看表了
Jake: Check the watch.
Alice: 坐后边玩手机
Alice: Sitting in the back playing on my phone.
Alice: 感觉晕车了
Alice: I feel car sick.
Jake: 到了是吧
Jake: We're here, right?
Jake: 确实到了
Jake: We really are here.
Jake:进去
Jake: Let's go in.
Jake:进去进去找
Jake: Go in, go in and look.
Jake:拐拐拐
Jake: Turn, turn, turn.
其他人：够荒凉的
Others: It's so desolate.
Jake: 咱也不知道这是啥地
Jake: We don't even know what this place is.
Jake: 那行吧
Jake: Alright then.
其他人：是不就这
Others: Is it just here?
Shure:  好像 不是这个
Shure: Seems like this isn't it.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake: 我我等会
Jake: I'll, I'll wait a moment.
Jake: 我我我这边看看
Jake: I'll, I'll check over here.
Jake: 我这边也有地图可以看
Jake: I have a map here too.
Alice:是65号
Alice: It's number 65.
Jake: 往前走往前走一会
Jake: Walk forward a bit more.
其他人：信号不好
Others: The signal is bad.
Jake: 就这个就左边这个
Jake: It's this one, the one on the left.
Shure:  对这个口停就行
Shure: Yeah, just stop at this entrance.
其他人： 这边手动的啊
Others: This one is manual, huh?
Alice: 我看手机了
Alice: I'm looking at my phone.
Alice: 搞得我
Alice: 难受
Alice: I feel sick.
Katrina:  我猜是往这吧
Katrina: I guess it's this way.
Alice:前
Alice: Forward.
Shure:  再往前是吗
Shure: Keep going forward, right?
Shure:  左拐吗还是右拐
Shure: Turn left or right?
Alice: 前
Alice: Forward.
Alice: 还往前
Alice: Keep going forward.
Shure:  再往前不是的吧
Shure: If we go further, it's not there, right?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Mm-hmm.
Alice: 还得往前
Alice: We still need to go forward.
Shure:  ah
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  啊
Shure:  可以啊
Shure: Alright then.
Alice: 有个西瓜虫
Alice: There's a pill bug.
Jake: 咱家是刚刚有猫吗
Jake: Did our house just get a cat?
Shure:  7多少多少人啊
Shure: How many people are there in the 70s?
Alice: 咪咪
Alice: Mimi
Shure:  不是如果你摁对了
Shure: No, if you press it right
Shure:  他直接自己开
Shure: It will open by itself
Alice: 咪咪
Alice: Mimi
Jake: 你你要先按一个键
Jake: You need to press one key first
Lucia: 不理我们他走了
Lucia: He ignored us and left
Jake: 在在对你等到他
Jake: Yes, wait until it
Jake: 哔对
Jake: Beeps, right
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay
Jake: 牛啊牛啊
Jake: Awesome, awesome
Shure:  哦太牛了
Shure: Oh, so awesome
Shure:  人类居然可以记住6位密码
Shure: Humans can actually remember a 6-digit code
Shure:  小心点那有那有
Shure: Be careful, what's that?
Jake: 经过了3天的训练
Jake: After 3 days of training
Shure:  人类记住这串密码需要3天的训练
Shure: It takes humans 3 days of training to remember this code
Shure:  AI 3秒用吗
Shure: AI needs 3 seconds, right?
Jake: 三秒开玩笑
Jake: 3 seconds, are you kidding?
Shure:  3毫秒
Shure: 3 milliseconds
Alice: 三秒
Alice: 3 seconds
Lucia: 这么简单的事情就不用3秒了是吧
Lucia: Such a simple thing doesn't even need 3 seconds, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Shure:  小艾开灯
Shure: Alexa, turn on the light
Jake: 3秒带开机吗
Jake: 3 seconds to boot up?
Jake: 三秒开机
Jake: 3 seconds to boot up
Jake: 放冰箱放完冰箱就结束
Jake: Put it in the fridge, and once you're done, it's over
Lucia: 我的留言板
Lucia: My message board
Lucia: 不是留言板
Lucia: Not the message board
Lucia: 就是那个软木的那个照片墙
Lucia: It's that corkboard photo wall
Katrina:  这个肉要腌吗
Katrina: Does this meat need marinating?
Katrina:  还是说先放冰箱
Katrina: Or should we put it in the fridge first?
Alice:哎呦我想吐
Alice: Ugh, I feel like throwing up
Lucia: 这个东西
Lucia: This thing
Lucia: 它怎么这么大呀
Lucia: Why is it so big?
Lucia: 我以为它就一点点呢
Lucia: I thought it was just a little bit
Lucia: 装起来就好
Lucia: Just pack it up and it's fine
Katrina:  把肯德基扔了
Katrina: Throw the KFC away.
Shure:  我每天放冰箱里
Shure: I put it in the fridge every day.
Shure:  就是留一天扔掉是吗
Shure: So, you leave it for a day and then throw it away?
Shure:  好饿好饿
Shure: So hungry, so hungry.
Shure:  好困好困好累好累
Shure: So sleepy, so sleepy, so tired, so tired.
Lucia: 哎这太夸张了
Lucia: Hey, this is too much.
Lucia: 算了一会再看他
Lucia: Forget it, we'll check on him later.
Katrina:  鸡蛋呢
Katrina: Where are the eggs?
Katrina:  扔了
Katrina: Thrown away.
Shure:  放放放
Shure: Put, put, put.
Lucia: 前两天买的那个
Lucia: The ones we bought a few days ago.
Shure:  导完
Shure: Finished.
Lucia: 把新的再补充进去
Lucia: Replace it with new ones.
Shure:  导完就
Shure: Once finished...
Lucia: 再不吃可能坏了
Lucia: If we don't eat it soon, it might spoil.
Jake: yes yes
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure:  为什么他要听RMB
Shure: Why does he listen to RMB?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure:  这个小狗
Shure: This little dog.
Jake: RNB
Jake: RNB.
Lucia: 哦对芒果
Lucia: Oh right, the mango.
Alice: 这能喝的水吗
Alice: Is this water drinkable?
Shure:  不用不用
Shure: No need, no need.
Shure:  电子版扫描就行
Shure: Just scan the electronic version.
Tasha: 门被开过了
Tasha: The door was opened.
Tasha: 你刚开的是吧
Tasha: You just opened it, right?
Alice: 啊
Alice: Huh?
Lucia: 我们晚上可以把
Lucia: We can...
Katrina:  这4个吃了吧
Katrina: Eat these four tonight.
Lucia: 让我们那啥
Lucia: Let us...
Lucia: 做那些甜品的时候需不需要用
Lucia: When making those desserts, do we need to use them?
Jake: 吃
Jake: Eat.
Jake: 今晚做什么呀
Jake: What are we making tonight?
Katrina:  对这个吗
Katrina: For this?
Jake: 你你烤他甜点
Jake: You bake him some desserts.
Lucia: 可以先放一下
Lucia: We can put it aside first.
Lucia: 然后如果用不着了再把它吃掉
Lucia: And if we don't need it, we can eat it later.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This...
Jake: 热量爆炸是吧
Jake: Calorie explosion, right?
Lucia: 芒果
Lucia: Mango.
Lucia: 怎么给我一种好像要尽快吃它的感觉
Lucia: Why does it feel like we need to eat it quickly?
Jake: 今天就吃
Jake: Let's eat it today.
Tasha: 那就今天就吃
Tasha: Then let's eat it today.
Jake: 今天今天围绕着他能做什么
Jake: Today, let's focus on what we can do with it.
Katrina:  was ice cream
Katrina: was ice cream
Tasha: 什么都行
Tasha: Anything is fine.
Lucia: 对会今天把它做了
Lucia: Yeah, let's make it today.
Jake: 对今天围绕着他
Jake: Yes, today let's focus on it.
Shure:  我我们我可以
Shure: I, we, I can...
Shure:  我们可以养小芒狗
Shure: We can raise a little mango dog.
Lucia: 养小芒狗
Lucia: Raise a little mango dog?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah?
Jake: 哈哈哈芒果核这个我知道
Jake: Hahaha, I know about mango pits.
Shure:  哈哈哈知道那个吗
Shure: Hahaha, do you know that?
Alice: 就那个芒果盒
Alice: Just that mango box.
Tasha: 芒果皮芒果狗是吧嗯
Tasha: Mango skin, mango dog, right?
Shure:  芒果核对
Shure: Mango pit, right.
Lucia: 哦没反应过来
Lucia: Oh, I didn't get it.
Alice: 让他把它嗦嗦嗦
Alice: Let him suck it clean.
Shure:  对嗦嗦干净点
Shure: Yes, suck it clean.
Lucia: 行今天晚上的活动就是养小小芒果
Lucia: Fine, tonight's activity is raising a little mango.
Katrina:  你住一楼是吧
Katrina: You live on the first floor, right?
Katrina:  那直接放一楼呗
Katrina: Then just put it on the first floor.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Alice: 这个放冰箱
Alice: Put this in the fridge.
Lucia: 芒果核
Lucia: The mango pit.
Shure:  不行今天太多了
Shure: No, there's too much today.
Katrina:  对放一楼冰箱
Katrina: Yes, put it in the first-floor fridge.
Shure:  明天明天养吧
Shure: Let's raise it tomorrow.
Katrina:  因为他那个可能
Katrina: Because it might...
Shure:  工作量爆棚了有点
Shure: The workload is overwhelming.
Alice: 今天晚上吃这个
Alice: Let's eat this tonight.
Jake: 养芒果要工序很多吗
Jake: Does raising a mango require a lot of procedures?
Lucia: 用就一直搁那吸那个芒果盒就行了
Lucia: Just keep it there and let it suck on the mango box.
Alice: eyes
Jake: 一直吃是吧
Jake: Just keep eating, right?
Shure:  缩干净一点就好
Shure: Suck it clean.
Lucia: 然后洗一洗
Lucia: Then wash it.
Jake: 好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure:  就是迷惑行为
Shure: It's just confusing behavior.
Jake: 迷惑行为是吧不知道
Jake: Confusing behavior, right? I don't know.
Shure:  人类为什么会把一个植物的种子
Shure: Why do humans treat the seeds of a plant
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  当成一个宠物
Shure: like a pet?
Shure:  why human will
Shure: Why would humans do that?
Jake: 您好
Jake: Hello
Jake: 6:11
Shure:  我靠那是7点 能吃啊
Shure: Damn, that's 7 o'clock. Can we eat that?
Jake: 7点开始可达到
Jake: It starts at 7 o'clock
Jake: 7点开始做
Jake: Starts cooking at 7
Alice: 开始做快8点吃
Alice: Start cooking and eat around 8
Shure:  能快速的把我这个先导完吗
Shure: Can you quickly finish this part for me?
Jake: 哈哈哈呃没没法快
Jake: Hahaha, no, it's not possible to do it fast.
Tasha: 哎牛奶怎么拿出来了
Tasha: Hey, why is the milk out?
Alice: 是早上的时候吧
Alice: Was it from the morning?
Alice: 没事
Alice: It's okay
Lucia: 现在应该还不至于坏
Lucia: It shouldn't be spoiled yet
Shure:  那个蛋液好像够呛
Shure: The egg mixture seems a bit off
Jake: 蛋液怎么会呢
Jake: How can the egg mixture be off?
Shure:  那可以停了吗这个先
Shure: Can we pause this for now?
Jake: 结束了吧结束了吧
Jake: It's over, it's over
Shure:  结束了吧
Shure: It's over
Shure:  我这个快结束
Shure: I'm almost done with this
Lucia: 能放下吗
Lucia: Can you put it down?
Alice:不太能
Alice: Not really
Jake: 来快快结束
Jake: Come on, quickly finish it
Katrina:  面包要放冰箱吗
Katrina: Should we put the bread in the fridge?
Shure:  不然的话大家那吃吃上就得饿死了
Shure: Otherwise, everyone might starve while waiting to eat
Alice:不太能
Alice: Not really
Lucia: 面包
Lucia: Bread
Lucia: 要不咱们拿到楼上去放楼上冰箱
Lucia: How about we take it upstairs to the fridge?
Lucia: 菜就不放了吧
Lucia: Don't refrigerate the vegetables then
Lucia: 一会直接直接用吧
Lucia: We'll use them directly later
Jake:等会吧他们已经关了没关系
Jake: Wait a bit, they're already closed, it's okay
Shure: 先把我的去导上
Shure: Let me finish this first
Lucia: 这个也得放冰箱
Lucia: This also needs to go in the fridge
Lucia: 榴莲这个也要放冰箱吧
Lucia: The durian also needs to go in the fridge, right?
Katrina:  放一楼冰箱吧
Katrina: Let's put it in the downstairs fridge
Lucia: 冷冻
Lucia: Freeze it
Lucia: 冷冻的话就放一
Lucia: If we're freezing, put it in the...
Lucia: 楼冰箱就可以了
Lucia: The fridge upstairs will do.
Alice: 这榴莲是准备烤着吃还是怎样的
Alice: Are we baking this durian or what?
Tasha: 都可以
Tasha: Either way is fine.
Jake: 休息时间
Jake: Break time.
Jake: 不得工作
Jake: No working allowed.
Jake: 结束了结束关了吧
Jake: It's over, let's wrap it up.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 线呢
Jake: Where's the cable?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice:啊没事是口红
Alice: Oh, it's nothing, just lipstick.
Jake: 啊这能没事吗
Jake: Oh, is this really nothing?
小Shure: 完了还是YSL的口红
Shure: Oh no, it's YSL lipstick.
Jake: 完了
Jake: Oh no.
小Shure: 应该没事他比电子设备抗摔一些
Shure: It should be fine, it's more durable than electronic devices.
Jake: 哦行
Jake: Oh, alright.
小Shure: 这谁的
Shure: Whose is this?